thank you and I have news for all of you
before we begin that this is actually a
safe space for an hour and a half you
will not hear any mention of brexit and
that is my promise to you for now and a
warm welcome to you all as we debate the
battle force free speech trigger warning
safe spaces microaggressions and no
platforming I'm going to start by saying
something uncharacteristically odd so
bear with me I'm going to make a huge
assumption and you are welcome to prove
me wrong
throughout the course of the evening
based on what we think we know of the
demographic here the geography in the
heart of Westminster the instincts and
the appetite of our audiences here I'm
going to assume that most of you come
here tonight because you espouse free
speech because you defend free speech to
the death we play with Dangerous Ideas
here and you like that and you have come
my assumption to have your minds opened
perhaps even changed so the idea of not
encouraging people to air their
long-held views or not say things in
their particular way might be anathema
to our audience here tonight it might
shock you
it might disgust you but today I'm going
to ask you to take your imagination your
tolerance for an even longer walk than
you normally do and I'm going to ask you
to be open to the idea that free speech
is not always okay I'm going to ask you
to listen to the idea that language
might sometimes have to be adjusted
perhaps even censored and if you are
truly in that place tonight where you're
willing to listen to everything even the
views that tell you some ideas are too
dangerous to say out loud then I think
you will be better placed to appreciate
tonight's event with balance
that's the end of my lesson I'm going to
introduce our speakers a wonderful lot
here Jonathan hight is the social and
cultural psychologist author of the
coddling of the American mind have good
intentions and bad ideas are set up for
general set up a generation for failure
Jonathan is over here for a week his
professor at New York University and
he'll be signing copies of his book
afterwards in the foyer a K and a
Andrews is a professor of Black Studies
at Birmingham City University author of
Back to Black retelling black radicalism
for the 21st century
Alan a penny is an activist journalist
and online editor at red pepper magazine
and rabbi Lord Sachs chief rabbi until
2013 recent author of not in God's name
confronting religious violence who is
also taught at new university as well
but we're going to start with Jonathan
our guest for the evening as it were and
a warm welcome to you and take us
through the problem that you're writing
about your book is about the the
coddling of American minds and the fears
you have for campuses and for students
right certainly well first thanks so
much to IQ squared for bringing us all
together here a lot of my work is on how
we need viewpoint diversity we need
people to challenge us to make us
smarter and I think this format rather
than a formal debate to bring people
been writing about this together in a in
a collegial way to who probably gonna
take opposite views on many things I
think is a productive and really
enjoyable format so thank you to IQ
squared and to all of you for coming out
tonight the there are two related
problems that have that have sort of
flooded into the United States become
very visible in the last three or four
years they weren't really visible before
then so I'll just very briefly state
them in that I hope will set us up for a
discussion the first is that we have I'd
say a mental health crisis for boys and
a mental health catastrophe for girls
what I mean by that is that rates of
anxiety and depression were fairly
stable in the early from 2000 to 2010
and then they begin rising very sharply
for boys rates of made
depression are up about 30% for girls
they're up about 40% some people say
this is just self-report it's not real
but rates of hospital admission for
self-harm are up in the same way for
girls not for boys though for suicide in
the United States suicide for teenage
boys is up 25% from the first decade of
the century if you look at the rise to
the last 2 or 3 years 25 percent
increase for girls it's 70 percent 7-0
percent increase I just looked at the
numbers for the UK but on my way over
here The Guardian has had a lot of
really good coverage of the various
studies that have come out it's the
exact same thing you two have no rise at
all in hospital admissions for boys boys
are not cutting themselves more but your
girls are going to the hospital much
more because they cut their bodies and
are bleeding
you also have even though the suicide
rate I think was in England and Wales
even though that suicide rate is going
down to historic levels overall the rate
for teenage girls has reached its
highest level ever
you also have about a 60 or 65 percent
increase in completed suicides for
English English girls English and Welsh
girls so there's a mental health
catastrophe going on we don't really
know what causes it but the best the the
most likely explanations are the
combination of social media which is
much harder on girls than boys and the
vast vast overprotection
that we in the United States we decided
to stop letting our kids out to tell
them the world is dangerous to tell them
that if they're ever not watched by an
adult they will be abducted we started
telling them this in the 1980s and
especially in the 1990s just as our
crime rate was plummeting we taught them
that life is so dangerous that they
shouldn't be allowed outside we deprive
them of free play so we don't know for
sure but we have a mental health crisis
it begins with kids born in 1995 we call
them gen Z or Gen Zed you would say or
the or I Gen for the internet generation
so when this generation arrives on
campus in the United States that's
around age 18 they come to the
University so in nineteen twenty
thirteen they first the first members of
Gen Z Gen Zed come to campus
and that's when all of these things
start none of us had heard of these
terms practically but by 2014 in a few
school students were asking for
protections from words books speakers
ideas they were treating them as though
they were dangerous of course students
can protest and have protested words
books speakers and ideas but they never
before said if this is presented if this
person comes on I or someone will be
traumatized harmed damaged this was new
we call this in the book who have Greg
Luciano and I call it safety ISM though
the worship of safety that that the the
view of the world as safe versus
dangerous Americans now young Americans
talk about emotional safety we used to
call it emotional discomfort socrates
reveled in creating emotional discomfort
on the way to learning many of us are
reluctant to do that now
because if I create emotional discomfort
and my students they might take that as
that they're unsafe and there's a number
to call there's an email to call to
report me even from class they can
report me if they think I've made them
unsafe just coming you have actually
changed the way you teach because of
your own worries yes I used to be a
provocative teacher I do not provoke
anymore I just play it straight I don't
tell jokes I don't show many videos
because it's happened to you personally
yeah it happens to a lot of people so we
all share stories when I started this in
2015 people thought that we were
exaggerating we're taught to talk about
a few anecdotes because it was just
starting then now it has spread so far
that even though most students are fine
most students are not depress they want
to learn they want to be exposed but if
you have a class of 300 students you now
have to teach to the most sensitive
student because any one of them can
report you give us an example of how you
think this is manifesting itself on
campuses in the US what what have you
actually seen in concrete terms so let's
see what what have I seen so we're very
careful about exploring hypotheses that
could be taken as contrary to received
wisdom on politically sensitive topics
let's take gender for example so it's
commonly said that women earn
be present as much as men now
that's a true fact in the United States
but that doesn't account for hours work
or job picked if you correct for those
then we're up in the 90s but it sounds
better to say that women are only paid
70% as much as men for the same work any
social scientist knows that's a
meaningless statistic unless you equate
for the kind of job and the hours worked
but I have seen social scientists I've
seen people say this from the stage that
women are only paid 70% as much and I've
seen another social scientists who know
that that's not true won't say anything
because you don't want to be called
sexist you don't want to be seen as
challenging as somehow denying or
minimizing the problem and at what point
do you think the students have the upper
hand do you think that students now
dictate what is being taught and what is
being said on campuses well you have to
think about in terms of everybody is
making a calculation as they walk
through we're all caught in a minefield
we're all walking through a world in
which one word we say this is true for
everybody faculty students everybody one
one word one thing you say can be
misreported or properly recorded on
Twitter and it blows up into something
so this we're all stuck in this and this
is one of the reasons for the mental
health crisis what we know from surveys
that we've conducted I run an
organization or used to be called
heterodox Academy we've surveyed
students what we know is that they are
afraid to speak up in class or many of
them report that they self-censor mostly
because they're afraid of other students
professors are mostly afraid of other
students the students again gen Zed
which grew up with the ability to block
things that they don't want a lot of
people they don't want they're very
adept at social media and so what's
happened is we don't trust each other we
don't we it's very difficult for
professors to trust their students we
can trust most of them but that's not
enough you talk about antifragility now
I know that's a phrase that goes up back
to I think it's Nassim Taleb isn't it
but you use this phrase antifragility to
talk about an inability to have
resilience yes this is the most
important concept in the book and so
I'll just I can lay it out very quickly
and if we if we all if we have this on
the table everything else will make more
sense so many things this you know this
is fragile and if I drop it it will
break and it won't be better it will be
broken and so we give kids plastic cups
because plastic is resilient but if a
kid drops a plastic cup it doesn't get
better there are a few things that need
to be dropped there are a few things
that have to be challenged in order to
configure themselves so the immune
system is the best example if you
protect your kids from bacteria and
peanuts they will have more autoimmune
diseases and more likely to have peanut
allergies so the immune system requires
exposure to all sorts of things well it
turns out human beings are anti fragile
human beings require we have to
experience stress exclusion teasing
insults we have to experience these
things in small doses as kids to set the
social system that allows it to wire
itself ups that we can face larger
things by the time we're adults in the
United States now we have gone so far
towards protecting kids my daughter when
she was in third grade last year in New
York City public schools the girls would
form play groups on the playground and
hers was the kitty cat club and only
members of the kitty cat Club could hang
out in a certain place and so the
teacher said well you know she led them
through why we can't exclude people it's
wrong to exclude people well okay it's a
good discussion to have but if my
daughter would go all the way through
schooling without having those
experiences when she gets to college she
won't be able to handle small things
that's what we think is happening kids
are actually anti fragile in the United
States and in Britain you've been
raising kids as though they're fragile
one of your head teachers recently
banned snowball fights because what if
someone gets hit in the eye if we
protect kids from small risks they don't
learn how to face larger risks and I'm
gonna pick up with Eleanor now lucky you
you're you're our representative you are
what do you prefer i gen or Zen Jen Zed
or you choose no if you want I reserve
that for my closest friends let's talk
about the things that Jonathan has just
mentioned their stress exclusion insults
teasing do you feel that those are areas
that you should try and protect
young people from or did you actually
agree with most of what he said well I
think the what Jonathan's questions
Jones's questions attempt to essentially
frame what is a political problem as a
problem that can be reduced to and
solved on the level of like personal
psychological robustness and I think
that movement is something that is
inherently flawed because what we're
facing now is a series of overlapping
political crises the students on
campuses across the country across the
world are attempting to develop
frameworks and epistemological tactics
and organizational tactics in order to
change that and yes sometimes those look
uncomfortable to the kind of colonists
who are triggered enough to write an
article about how they don't have a
platform in a national newspaper however
I think we're in danger of calling the
people pointing out the problem the
problem we're in danger of massively
misdiagnosing the real existential
threats to our freedom of speech which
do exist but they don't look like the
very overblown handful of cases of
students on campus and over using
tactics such as you know such as no
platforming or such as trigger warnings
they look like you know the mass
surveillance that's going on in our
society they look like government
collecting data on Muslim students
through prevent legislation they look
like the rise and rise of the far-right
who have explicitly mobilized around
things like shutting down free speech
they like to play victims and they like
to spin a narrative of martyrdom but
really as the as Donald Trump has shown
us they have very little interest in in
the game that we think they we think
we're playing they have no interest in
civility
they have no interest in truth and they
have no interest in freedom of speech
and what we're in danger of doing here
and I use that word purposefully don't
worry
is having exactly the kind of concept
creep that you talk about in the book
right from freedom of speech as freedom
from prosecution and freedom from when
you will voice your opinion to a kind of
freedom from consequence
so what we're expected is that powerful
speakers often powerful right-wing men
are expected to be invited along to very
prestigious platforms to air their views
and not be challenged for it and to me
that's not that's not free speech it's
it's the exact opposite
it's using free speech that's using the
trappings of free speech to essentially
protect people who are already powerful
from being challenged it's it's
essentially flying alive one of the most
fundamental rights in our democracy and
you know wearing it's dead skins so then
I'm going to come in here because um you
make it these are really important
points I think now I wouldn't have gone
straight for no platforming because I
think that's probably exactly the area
that you think people push this debate
onto when it's if you like the pinnacle
of it but since you are doing that and
you're talking about the far right let's
put some examples here the obvious one
is Steve Bannon who was an Oxford
talking at the Union so in that
situation you would not want Steve
Bannon anywhere near your University
well I think that well first of all my
University UCL represent has an
inglorious history of things like white
supremacist conferences eugenics that
kind of thing so the University in and
of itself isn't this kind of like
sanctified repository of of knowledge
that cannot be that is apolitical and
cannot be questioned there are cultural
institutions they live in our society
they are as flawed and as struggling and
in evolution as the rest of us right I
think what we need to need to understand
is that the University as a cultural
institution also conveys a stamp of
approval and that is a stamp of approval
but I don't want to see given to someone
who has no interest in protecting free
speech and does pose and the politics
that he has espoused does pose an
existential threat to you know me and
people like me I think what we need to
remember here this is that free speech
is fundamentally important because words
have an impact and to say that like we
shouldn't consider the impact of those
words in a limited number of cases such
as such as the you know fascism I think
is ludicrous and I think is an under
analysis of the importance of free
speech let me bring in Lord Sachs bad
luck you're both called Jonathan so you
get Jonathan tonight and you get Lord
Sachs just to make it easier Lord
doesn't get anywhere in they'll say how
do you do mr. Rais is a really critical
point there which is when you look at
the university is it a a platform is it
an open platform in which any idea can
be shared or rejected or explored or
whatever or is it a community that has
its own identity and you have to be
careful as a university what signals you
are sending out who you welcome and how
seriously those words of people who
might be undesirables are taken to me a
university I was the first member of my
family to go to university it was a huge
culture shock
my dad bless him left school at the age
of 14 and always we felt his four boys
that we were getting the education he
wished he'd had
so I mean and and and I found something
in the university I you know I grew up
as a Jewish pupil at a school called
Christ College so I knew I was you know
a cognitive minority but that didn't
bother me because I've often argued that
Judaism is a civilization all of whose
canonical texts anthologies of arguments
and I think that's all God actually does
in the in the Bible is argue with people
and the people he loves arguing with
people I gave round Moses Jeremiah and
Joe these are the heroes of faith
there's no such thing there's no Hebrew
word for obedience no just work that out
there's a religion with a lot of
Commandments but no word for obedience
so Jews always develop this kind of
intellectual antifragility because we
are used to being a cognitive minority
now I didn't know what on earth was
going to happened in university I found
it very very disorienting at first
meaning people of a kind that I'd never
met before public school kids all sorts
of attitudes that were very alien to me
but I found myself studying philosophy
with one of the world's great
philosophers the late Sir Bernard
Williams and he was a very principled
atheist a lapsed Catholic and I was a
lot more pious than I am now and you
know and I wondered what's gonna happen
here and the fact is but we had the most
extraordinary conversation but he never
once made fun of my faith never once
ridiculed it only challenged me to make
a a coherent argument a lucid argument
it challenged me at every point but the
fact that a guy like that was willing to
listen to somebody like me gave me the
courage gave me the antifragility that I
was able to do stuff that not all that
many Orthodox rabbis had done before
which is take a Jewish voice into the
public domain through broadcasting
through the press knowing that most
people who will hear
message when I where I'm coming from and
we'll probably disagree but saying
society is it's a symphony score choral
symphony scored for many voices and that
to me is the beauty of the university
and why becomes so important when we are
disaggregating our societies in tune on
communicating sects of the like-minded
now all the cries of pain that come from
excluded marginalized groups have to be
heard but they have to be heard by all
of us I'm in favor of free speech
because they're only out of that
conversation that Democratic
conversation do we arrive at a society
where we can all feel we have a share we
are heard so that for me is the
importance of the University of why I'm
so bothered the way the university has
gone the way of rest of society where is
it ought to be a safe space in which we
are willing to give a respectful hearing
to views opposed to our own knowing that
our own views will be given a respectful
hearing despite the fact that many of
those doing the hearing don't agree with
a word I say now out of that democratic
conversation come real solutions and
real listening to other people's pain
otherwise if you disaggregate society
into little silos and little boxes of of
of Google filters and Facebook Likes
then you get non communicating groups
who can only fear feel towards other
groups fear and anxiety and that's just
bad for all of us Kenzo why is
[Applause]
[Music]
why is Jonathan Sacks wrong on that why
why is the way to immunize ourself
against this fragility against safety
ISM not just to hear everyone and allow
the merits of what is being said to
dictate who is listened to in his
important because this is this fantasy
version of the University where it is an
institution is based on equality and
reason and there's no power relations in
its discussion the actually irony of
this conversation is that it is rooted
in frigidity but it's the fragility of
the white elite and actually the white
male elite in particular as an
alternative way we can look at this
picture where in 1965 in the UK and in
the u.s. only 5% of the population went
to university rich white men now what's
happened over the last 50 years is it's
been opened up you've got women you've
got minorities you've got LGBTQ
communities and not ironically not
surprisingly these are the groups who
are saying that the universities are
harmful the universities we need
protection from these institutions which
not not too long ago would have
determined that I wasn't a human being
have the same curriculum and bases of
knowledge that say that I am NOT a human
being these are the spaces into which we
have put minorities women etc and then
we are somehow surprised when people say
we need a safe space or actually maybe I
need a trigger warning to learn about
European enlightenment because it's
basically telling me that I can't think
right and it's the fragility of the
elite who will come into this space and
now hear the actual voices of minorities
right of people saying you need to work
differently because this isn't gonna
wrong for us and I'm supposed to feel
sorry for you because you have to change
how you how you respond I mean that's
this is a deeply fragile argument but on
the other side just but I'm gonna let
Jonathan respond to that why do you
think you need safe spaces to learn
about this though that's the question
why do you need to be protected from
learning about what happened in history
what happened in literature what
happened in classics well it's
interesting the mental health statistics
are interesting because mental health
you
mentally or more generally if you're a
minority that's there applies in
universities the dropout rate for
minorities is higher in universities the
more less likely to get a good degree in
universities why because actually the
curriculum the environment everything
about it is alienating to you right
so with students as a win Africa if you
feel offended and actually are there is
a I don't I use the word violence but I
don't mean that in it what I mean is
learning an institution so for example
look around this was what my university
experience was one black face and
literally a hundred white people right
learning only from learning only stuff
written by white Europeans right in
environments with dead white men hanging
on the wall right that's an actual
violence based on you so if I say I need
a different a space where I can just
have a bit of quiet from me from the
hegemonic whiteness that people are
asking but is there any different to
Jonathan Sacks you know going to
Christchurch school as a Jew I mean
isn't it how you deal with your minority
vulnerability that then informs whether
you become stronger or weaker from it I
mean it is a there's a kind of a look on
some level I agree that's what society
is like I have to learn how to deal with
racism right well I got that's not
really a good argument for universities
and the other flip side to this is ah
the people the elite in these
universities who make all this noise
about no platform etc well more than
likely going to jobs where they won't
see any diversity this is the university
is the only time that some people will
ever have a diverse experience and maybe
they should spend that time listening to
the people who never talk to you again
because it may be their only opportunity
um that needs addressing okay so there's
a diff team in psychology that thinking
is for doing we we think in terms of
what are we trying to do and then we use
cognitive processes appropriate to reach
that goal and so if what we're doing is
trying to find the truth what we're
doing is exploration discovery we
organize ourselves in a certain land
we're all oriented towards claims and
counterclaims this is what we think of
ourselves as doing it kandi may be right
that this is
utilized view there's a lot else going
on this is what Talmudic scholarship is
about there's a phrase in the in the
Bible maybe some proverbs iron sharpens
iron we get smarter from contesting so
if that's what we're trying to do we
have one set of norms and that's going
to favor favored fairly broad conception
of speech free speech another thing that
we might do in universities is help
students grow and I've looked at a lot
of university mission statements and
they usually are about discovery and
growth or learning now if we do that
it's going to be a different mindset but
it's going to be a kind of a somewhat
therapeutic mindset of what do students
need and what do they need to grow and
here I think is where we might disagree
on what the right what the best way is
but here I want to quote that the
smartest thing I've read about this so
Van Jones is a democratic activist in
United States he was in the Obama
administration and when he was invited
to speak at the University of Chicago of
two years ago and they had just had a
member of the Trump administration had
been there there was a movement to kick
him out to not let him speak and David
Axelrod was a political consultant for
Obama asked Van Jones what he thought of
that and Van Jones said something I
thought that was beautiful and and very
wise he said if there's a certain
conception of safety I mean physical
safety or if people are screaming racial
epithets at you of course you should be
safe from that he said but there's
another conception of safety which is
terrible terrible for students he said I
don't want you to hear he's speaking to
the especially the the Democratic
activists in the audience he says I
don't want you to be safe
emotionally I don't want you to be safe
ideologically I want you to be strong
and that's different he says he says I'm
not going to take the weights out of the
gym this is the gym
he says expose yourself to things expose
yourself to people this will make you
stronger so we can be organized for
growth and learning but the third game
the third game we play we're very good
at is victory this is what we do in the
public square discourse in the public
square is terrible because we're not
bound into a community that has to find
references for our claims we're not
trying to help people we're trying to
crush people defeat people and there's a
time and a place for this what I see
happening when we talk about in chapter
3 of the book
is we call it great untruth number three
life is a battle between good people and
evil people and increasingly what I'm
seeing in American universities is
students are being taught to look out on
society look at all the people out there
don't see people see groups locked in
struggle with groups in an eternal
zero-sum game the white men are the
group on top they're the bad people they
always have been they always will be
unless we all organize to take them down
now there may be some truth to that in
some institutions but this is most
prevalent at the most egalitarian
American universities which are just
about the most anti-racist places one
can think of they're not happening at
most other American universities so the
the norms of combat the norms of victory
in the public square make it very
difficult to do our work in university
the mind prepared for battle is not a
mind prepared for learning I want to
bring back a Hindi's point an Alanis
point because if everyone were learning
in the same way from the same starting
point maybe that would be true your mind
is open you receive everything if you
come in as 10% to a roomful of 90% then
there is immediately that imbalance
which needs to be corrected aren't you
talking about progress here I'll let you
argue I just think it's to imagine that
women the LGBT people that minority
people aren't already some of the most
robust people out there because to
survive which is what we're talking
about and when when we're using this
like you know psychological framework to
survive to thrive to flourish in this
deeply deeply oppressive society in many
ways you need to be robust I would love
it if what we were talking about when we
were talking about safety culture is a
set of tactics where I didn't need to
think about sexism I didn't need to
worry about anti-semitism for another
day brilliant I can just take these
tools
and put myself a little bubble and you
know so what if I get paid less at work
and so what if I you know get assaulted
on the night bus home I'm sick that's
not what we're talking about here what
we're talking about here is creating the
spaces necessary for people who are
already robust to encounter the things
to confront head-on the structures that
day to day we don't have the mental time
to address now for me that's not about
shutting down debate those are precisely
the conditions it takes to confront
honestly and with intellectual rigor the
kind of structures on which our society
is found it now in the book we talk
about being triggered in the right
circumstances as in CBT as a as a
necessary process for growth
I completely agree I've actually I've
had a PTSD diagnosis myself I've been
through CBT cognitive behavioral therapy
have or therapy by the book but you took
PTSD thank you but that's precisely what
safe spaces are they are structures
where people can people can allow
themselves to confront material and to
bring new perspectives in to
institutions that usually exclude them
now as an academic I want to embrace
that I want to embrace what is in
flourishing a proliferation of
viewpoints and of course the ways in
which those viewpoints are brought in
and addressed and not going to look the
same as the ways in which we were used
to in the past because the people and
the perspectives are changing right
that's one of the gifts of feminist
epistemology right that there are all
kinds of ways of inquiry and all kinds
of ways of knowing things and we should
be embracing that that's not an t
intellect let me just ask you that in
terms of embracing views you don't like
would you say you would not want to hear
a
sexist voice on campus you would not
want to hear a right-wing voice on
campus or an extreme right-wing voice on
campus this is to help us out in terms
of because the problem is that you are
deciding where those lines offset what
is unpalatable to you I mean I think
that's it's completely like I'm not
saying you want mischaracterize I'm
saying that this isn't this
characterization right sorry it's very
convenient mischaracterization if you
want to paint this like tiny minority of
the left as the real enemies of society
and distract from everything else that's
going on but okay cool what's happening
here is to say that like when what
safety what safe spaces is to say that
what we need to do when we're in this
room is to be mindful of how our
language and how our behaviors affect
other people and this is a space in
which we can confront the structures
that we move through every day in a
considered compassionate way and what a
trigger warning is is not I'm not going
to read this book but I need to take a
breath take a little pause in order that
I can read this book and the hysteria
around having a 30 second port was all
leading to step out the room for a bit
is to me the real that's the realest
area here okay so if if it is just about
the use of language the use of kindness
of compassion there is nothing for Chief
Rabbi to disagree with there is that
well you know I'm always willing to
disagree so you get to be chief
but I mean you know I just I just wanna
frame to step back and put it in a
slightly larger frame one thing has
bothered me for the last 50 years we
have focused on two institutions one
favored by the left one favored by the
right namely the state and the market
the state is about the creation and
distribution of power market about the
creation and distribution of wealth and
the right tends to find market-based
solutions the left tends to fund state
based solutions I don't let anything
hang on that but it seems to me that we
have always historically had healthy
societies when we had a third arena
because the state and the market are
both about competition they're about
what in the short term is zero sum games
the more power I give away the less I
have the more money I give away the less
I have there has to be a third arena
which we sometimes called civil society
a key arena of which is the university
which is not about competition it's
about collaboration and cooperation and
we need to learn how to cooperate as
well as how to completely compete what I
object to and what is very dangerous is
if you turn the university into a
version of the market ie
you get privileged according to how you
can pay or you turn it into a version of
this state where what's really at stake
is relationships of power and candy
you've said that universities are to be
understood as relationships of power and
that to me is is it an allegation that
needs to be taken terribly seriously are
people using power to impose their views
on others or silenced views they don't
want to hear universities have to stand
aside as a third sector we will learn to
trust one another
listen to one another respect one
another's differences and I think we're
losing that and I can see left question
bear with me let me take your
imagination for a walk if you replace
the word University with gentleman's
club right which is what it may sound
like if you come from a minority that
does not expect you in it does that
change if instead of saying University
you say in this gentlemen's club we have
to you know push back against the rule
that doesn't allow women we have to push
back against the law that makes black
men feel uncomfortable does it then
change
look it says this son of a guy who sews
what is in Commercial Road are you you
know Lowry site sort of stuff yeah
that's exactly what University looked
like to me I've wandered into this
gentlemen's club where clearly I don't
belong and it was a scary experience I
have to say this and then I suddenly
discover that all these very very well
often aristocratic and public school
guys are willing to sit down and argue
and when we're talking seriously from
the heart with passion but with lucidity
all of a sudden most distinctions of
class and and and privilege just
disappeared and for a mote that that was
for me an epiphany that said to me this
isn't a gentlemen's club here is a place
where I as a Jew a cognitive minority
representing less than 1/2 of 1% of the
population of this country I have a
voice here I have a place here and the
same must apply to Black's it must apply
to LGBTQ it must apply to any minority
they have to feel this is not a club
that excludes me and therefore I won't
exclude the other voices in this club
but the truth is that's not what happens
and the idea that the university is a
third space that's not true the
university has always been an expression
of state power and market power
right so the university justified
slavery at a time when you need slavery
for example and going to this point
about 2010 it's been a big change what
happened in 2008 there was a major
financial crisis which Unleashed
neoliberalism in a way that had not been
seen on the university sector the
university sector is just a market like
there is no barrier to that at all and
when you look at things like fees you
feel away the price of accommodation if
you look at competition and market bit
that is probably the better explanation
for why you're having these problems
with students then because they're being
mollycoddled actually this university is
the market and the market is racism and
that market excludes people many
minorities and that's really the problem
we're talking about you and what really
is being said in safe spaces or no
platforming or trigger warnings if you
have a group of students now in this
market if you like and they are saying
we should be the ones who decide what
speech what what is OK speech because I
think we all agree that not if not all
speech is OK you wouldn't have a sama
bin Laden comment to the university
campus right but that's not just an
objective decision well maybe you
wouldn't I don't think most people would
right but I saw what you're always gonna
have no platform there's always a level
where you say look Holocaust denier
don't come to university right but who
is it that has the power to decide
whether Steve banner should come I would
argue if the students you should not be
the danza nearly and if the students get
together and say we don't want this
person then that's a perfectly fine
expression of their free will right to
speak so so I think we can all agree
that universities like most institutions
used to be like gentlemen's clubs used
to exclude women or people of African
descent I think we all agree that there
used to be enormous racism we can all
agree that many groups we can talk about
today as historically marginalized I
think we all agree to that and our
debate comes down to have we made no
progress a little progress or enormous
progress and if we've made enormous
progress should we continue or you might
think we've made little and therefore we
need to try a totally new way
so I'd like to share with you what
happened to me when I was on well this
when I was on a panel at soon after I
wrote an article in Atlantic with Gregg
look II honor from 2015 there was a
panel organized at the New York
University Law School to talk about this
and one of the the one of the
participants was a law student of Latin
American descent who was talking about
being a Latino student at NYU law and
she was talking about the the constant
violence perpetrated on her and I asked
her to elaborate on that what do you
mean violence like actual like physical
violence and she said no no not physical
violence but but violence nonetheless
and she said well I mean you have to
admit that this university was not built
for it was not designed for people like
me and I looked around the panel and I
said okay I'll agree to that wasn't
built for people like me I'm Jewish it
wasn't built for people like her she's
chinese-american it wasn't built for him
he's a gay half black British
philosopher wasn't built for any of us
isn't that wonderful
isn't that progress and to take the fact
of historical prejudice as a reason to
feel excluded today as a reason to dam
an institution that is trying its
hardest to overcome that to increase
diversity this is what we're talking
about with great untruth number two that
what we call the untruth of emotional
reasoning always trust your feelings if
your catastrophizing if you're
deliberately trying to if you're
deliberately telling students this
institution is against you see
oppression everywhere people here hate
you they will do anything to stop you
that's a really good recipe to
disempower them if you want to make the
black students at NYU Law fail tell them
that okay
take that phrase I don't mind which of
your answers stop seeing oppression
everywhere because that is ultimately
what's holding back minorities it's one
of the things you might actually be
appreciated I don't know I think it is
profoundly patronizing isn't it to say
that to respond to someone's cry of pain
as a rabbi sacks so so eloquently put
and with your pain is not valid your
pain is in fact the cognitive distortion
is a misdiagnosis of the world and I
think when went is to say that that
university students reason purely from
emotion is it's just untrue that is the
great untruth here but what we need to
talk about here is that when many
mainstream philosophers at the moment
Center emotional emotional factors like
intuition like private pain like
distress what that is is a corrective to
a long history of people who have
experienced depression being told you're
misdiagnosed in your situation you're
lying you're overestimating what's
happening to you when really all of
these are just historical tactics that
have been used to silence dissent and
forget people to shut up basically now
I'm not saying that that's what you're
doing
but I am saying that that is very
convenient for people who are trying to
do that and I'm sitting and I'm saying
that that of those kinds of convenient
narratives that we are inculcating in
our universities invite invite a kind of
very damaging framework and I'm not
talking about damaging as in like
discomforting I'm talking about damaging
to the fabric of exactly the kind of
free robust institution that we're all
invested in but I just want to come back
one thing that rabbi said it's that two
things when we are engaging in a free in
a free debate there is this kind of
sense of a contract there is a sense of
give-and-take that I disagree with your
views but I will respect them at yours
free speech and you disagree with my
views but you respect my free speech
that is not the case when you are
talking about Steve Steve and his many
compatriots that is not the case when
you are talking about the framework far
right because the far right is invested
politically and tactically in depriving
those rights from many many people and
yes Jewish people thank God have a
wonderful history of debate and arguing
Christ like I know that from like from
half of my family and it's one of my
favorite things about like going to see
my aunties but Jewish people also have a
very noble history of drawing a line
somewhere and that line is always always
to stop fascist mobilizing because we
know that they pose us a direct threat
that was the line that was drawn in
Kayla Street in 1936 that was the line
that was drawn in Lewisham
in 1978 and both of those times it
worked and we would be so naive to not
learn the lessons of history very
briefly if you want to come back I agree
with you hate speeches out but but it
does seem to me that I mean what Kant is
saying is that the university today is
not the one I went to and I agree with
you I agree with you let me be blunt if
I were today a member of Gen Z or Gen Z
I couldn't afford to go to university
none of my family could have afforded we
went with with with with no tuition fees
and with a government grant and if I
found myself having to go to university
pan enormous some burden myself with
that I could never have had the career
that I've had I could never have become
the person I became and therefore if I
were sitting where you're sitting I'd
also feel very angry and I think there's
there are a lot of groups in society
today who have justified reasons for
feeling very angry and I I really hear
that anger and I'm saying if if I'd been
born 40 years later or whatever I would
also feel angry the question is what do
you do with that anger a number one I
think it's terribly important to be able
to speak from that anger to actually
persuade people to listen to you and
take you seriously and that that is
obviously what I forgive the cliche but
that's what Martin Luther King did he
spoke to the better angels of our nature
there was a lot of anger in that man but
he nonetheless spoke in ways that evoked
not anger but but a sense that you know
what we have not lived up to our ideals
I think of James Baldwin for instance it
was doubly marginal of being both black
and gay who said one of the truest
things about about hate which we really
have to listen to today where there's a
lot of hates sloshing around he said I
think people cling on to their hate
because they're afraid that if they let
go of their hate they will have to
confront pain so when there's a lot of
pain going around that isn't able to be
expressed it generates hate so I hope
I've said to you I think I hear where
you're coming from but I still ask how
can we take that anger and do the anti
fragile thing turn those negative
energies into positive ones and I think
open conversation and reasoning together
is the best way of taking negative
energies and turning them into
constructive things I'm going to come to
questions in the audience in a moment
but hey Andy you get the last word in
this debate well I'm always a Malcolm X
Men personally so no baby tell you where
I'm coming from
and I just hate this Buddhist radicalism
I always want to put this into context
because we're talking about a reality
that does not exist if you are an ethnic
minority in this country you are less
likely to get into an elite University
you are less likely to get a good degree
you are let more likely to drop out you
are more likely to have mental health
issues you are less likely to get a job
after you graduate you are almost
impossible you're gonna see a black
lecturer or a black professor only a
hundred out of 18,000 in the whole
entire of the UK and you're not going to
see any black people in management these
institutions are not to the institutions
which you are set telling us these are
institutions which haven't changed
anywhere near as much as you were saying
and because the racism and sexism in the
misogyny is so deeply present this is
why the people who opened up a widen
access are saying that we need to think
differently and unfortunately because of
the fragility from the top you hear that
as oh there's something wrong with you
no there's something wrong with the
university and therefore we need to fix
it I'm I took if we can get the lights
hi yes I can see a lady with her hand up
there I'm going to take questions in
threes there's a lady here in the second
row right right so hi Karen Robinson
here I'm both from Democrats abroad UK
and also a social media strategist
professionally so I'm coming into it
this discussion from both social media
and a u.s. politics point of view and
I'm hoping that Jonathan can fill in
what I think is a missing part of his
argument that I didn't hear in his
conversation which is he talks about
young people being struggling with
crippling anxiety suicidal issues
serious psychological problems
afflicting this generation more so than
any other but he also then stipulates
that this must be because they have not
experienced the kind of bullying and
können and difficulty that perhaps his
generation has I don't see the evidence
for that and I would like to understand
more aware he's building that argument
out because from a political point of
view we certainly have seen the rise of
a bullying political culture and on
social media we certainly have seen
individual people and young people in
petite
more so than certainly my generation or
generations that have come since
experienced directly misogyny and racism
and political oppression directed at
them individually in a way that I don't
think previous subsequent generations
have seen so I'd like to kind of just
have them fill in that argument a little
bit thank you very much okay hi my name
is you today I'm a graduate that studied
international tourism management so I've
had a lot of knowledge on stuff to do
with all over the world and things like
that but as a brown-skinned woman sorry
this is my first time here and I'm quite
nervous but I just wrote down like a few
things that I've been thinking about
like over the week and especially what
we see in the news especially as a black
minority basically and what I noticed is
that in the news you tend to get these
students who are named as depressed
suicidal they went for a stage of
bullying and when it comes to for
example American schools where you've
got a white man shooting people in
school and then after then the media is
telling us that they suffered from
mental health but then on the other side
you've got black young men who are doing
absolutely well for themselves trying to
hustle their way through life and then
having a different like they looked at
in such a negative way but then it's
like they're classed as the big bad guy
so you think the perceptions the way the
media portrays people yeah is different
according to their skin color but yeah
thankfully first just because we're in
the UK storms EE he's a meet he's a
grime artist however he sponsored
minority students to go into Cambridge
because of this issue which has opened
many doors for us as well thank you so
thank you very much indeed
let me get the third mic yes sir hi I'm
18
I guess in the eyes of a lot of people
older than me that makes me like a
defend to the death free speech person
but I raised recently read Deborah
Lipstadt spoke denial and I was really
really interested to hear what you think
about of in the Holocaust yeah and I
think just in general in terms of
historical truths I'd be really
interested to see at which point you
would as you say draw the line in terms
of free speech like at which point can
you you know Deborah Lipstadt says you
know there there are facts and there are
lives and at which point can you just
get away with anything because of
freedom of speech right especially in
regards to Holocaust denial thank you
very much indeed right we can start with
you rabbi chief rabbi let's go backwards
let's go backwards and then we'll pick
up in that order
don't think you can talk to the the lady
from Democrats abroad and we'll all
dress I didn't catch your name I'm sorry
yep you couldn't a that's right we'll
pick up on that do you want to talk
about where you draw the line does your
does your need to step in override your
need to hear speech of all kinds the
important thing that happened with
Deborah Lipstadt and and denial is that
it wasn't Deborah who brought the case
against Irving it was David Irving
brought the case against her I think
Deborah believes as we believe that free
speech gets us beyond prejudice my
hatred because in the end there's such a
thing as historical fact so she never
sought to deprive him of his freedom to
speak I think there are some European
countries obviously Germany but others
likewise who have such searing
experiences what were done during the
Holocaust years that they did enact laws
banning whole
denial and so on and and that's got to
do with their own inner history you know
they needed time to heal those wounds
but Debra never sought to to do that and
if you really have confidence that you
are right then you never seek to silence
your opponents there's a very
interesting argument given that where we
are today in in in the world and
religions are turning inwards and ethnic
groups are turning inward and we're all
a little more fearful of one another
it's just worth remembering the history
of this free speech argument I think it
was the 12th century Muslim thinker
Islamic think of arrows who developed
the first case that I know of of a
religious defense of free speech saying
that if you're confident in your truth
then you welcome opponents who are as
strong as they possibly can be because
you know you're right
and that is picked up in the 16th
century by one of my ancestors Rabbi
Judah Loew II of Prague it is then
picked up in the 17th century by John
Milton in Areopagitica and it is then
picked up in the 19th century by the
secular thinker John Stuart Mill in his
tract on Liberty so it seems to me that
if you really have confidence in what
you believe you do not seek to limit
speech because you believe that truth
will win in the end
[Music]
a fabulous question sadly very relevant
well I think what you've hit on here is
the fact that what is sold to us as a
kind of right what is sold to us as
simply a neutral protection of free
speech that raises up everyone maybe
including some far-right people that we
happen to disagree with it's not
actually the case because what what's
happening is that people are making
choices right when you give someone a
platform you offer them a choice now I
have no interests in depriving in
depriving anyone of their free speech
but I do have an interests in resisting
the concept creep the means that we
equate freedom of speech and a right to
a national powerful platform because
those two things are not the same and I
think when we Institute I'm very
suspicious of state-based solutions to
things that should be worked out in the
public and civic sphere and these are
precisely those discussions but I think
what we need to be doing here is
examining why these choices are being
made and for instance that Milo
gianopolous was given a a lot of
platforms and a very sweet book deal on
the basis that he was this free speech
Crusader and that anyone who opposed him
and opposed his his absolute god-given
right to speak in front of thousands and
thousands of people which he could have
done anyway via the Internet which is
you know another point you can't
possibly know platform anyone ultimately
these days because of the technology you
know that seemed like a neutral choice
but as soon as he came out and said
something that people genuinely
disagreed with which was when he said
things in support of pedophilic
relations he instantly had his platforms
poles he had his book deal withdrawn
which indicates that people weren't
neutrally supporting free speech because
they certainly weren't giving those
kind of 250 thousand pound buck deals to
kind of you know like crusty and narcos
like rummaging through the bins at the
back of the publishing house as well
they were giving it to people who -
whose views were acceptable to their
world picture and it's those editorial
choices that we need to be examining and
that examination is part of nourishing a
free speech culture ok I'm going to ask
for some more hands I'm gonna let you
Jonathan
respond to you today and also to Karen
if we can just weave those two together
today was talking about how how badly
wrong the perception in the media is of
you know when when a white person does
something wrong when a black person does
something wrong how that gets conflated
and she talked about storm Z trying to
bring more black students into Cambridge
University a sort of sponsorship program
almost and Karen was talking about
bullying and why you would think that
they were not robust given how much
bullying actually goes on through social
media and through many other channels
now okay so on the other question down
here I don't have have much to say there
are still there are widespread
stereotypes there are norms and problems
within each institution in the United
States there are a lot of problems with
the criminal justice system I'm very as
we say in the book it's pretty clear
that we can understand what it means to
say there's institutional racism the
criminal justice system the universities
are just a different sort of place I
don't know as much about about the media
so I don't have a good answer to the
question down there but on the question
on antifragility let me clarify I
certainly didn't mean to say that
bullying is good for you that kids who
are bullied are gonna come out strong or
bullying especially when it goes on it's
if it goes on for weeks it really can
have a lasting impact chronic stress is
very bad for kids brains
I'm not saying bullying is good the
evidence that we refer that we cover in
the book is not about benefits of
bullying or even benefits of harm or
that the evidence is on the benefits of
free play unsupervised free play which
includes conflict and risk-taking that's
what there is clear evidence in animal
so rat pups and other animals that are
deprived of free play are then more
fearful and put in a new environment so
that at least matches on there have not
been clear experiments with human kids
we can't randomly assign half the kids
to not play and half to play but we do
make we do at least make the case that
it's unsupervised free play where the
kids face difficulty and have some
negative emotions that scene is what
seems to be beneficial if I could just
use the opportunity just comment down a
little bit on the free speech points
that I just want to get yeah lots more
voices in but ok so I actually agree
with a lot of what penny and her sister
have written and said on free speech
that there is no absolute right to free
speech it doesn't mean you have a right
to speak without consequences on a
college campus I don't think everyone
has a right to free speech if that means
you can yell whatever you want or say
obnoxious things so I think we actually
agree for the most part on the there
there are and have to be limitations on
speech in order to have the kind of
community that we want to have I also
agree that a lot of political
correctness is just being more polite
updating language so that it doesn't
alienate people unnecessarily so I think
on free speech we're actually not that
far apart the one thing that I would add
is that what we need on campus
especially in addition to trying to give
less offense we also have to learn to
take less offense and the reason I say
that is because we are trying so hard to
increase diversity and we are successful
the percentage of non-whites on all the
top schools keeps going up and up and up
and we're all proud of that if you're
going to bring people together
especially internationally if you have
more people who have Asperger's or other
mental mental illnesses you're going to
have huge numbers of misunderstandings
you're going to have language used in
all kinds of ways that could offend
people so yes we need to give less
offence but we it can't work unless we
have a general regimen of give people
the benefit of the doubt there's a
lovely phrase in your book
which is about the principle of charity
which is when somebody says something
that you find offensive you have to work
out whether it was intended to be or not
give it it's more its best reading out
its worst okay Andy I'm gonna bring
Internet so let me just get some hands
yes I'm going right to the back now
number three you choose me some myself
there's a very unlike green one I quite
like that one yeah dickweed arm right
there should we go with you Green Green
arm yes certainly the benefits of
wearing high vis clothing to a lecture
really quickly just interested in the
discussion about how universities can be
elite institutions we have members of
the panel from Great Britain members of
the panel from the United States I'm
myself Canadian I wonder the UK has
moved towards more expensive
post-secondary education in the United
States that's often been the case there
are state schools but American education
is generally more expensive than a
number of countries does the data bear
out for instance in countries where
post-secondary education is a lot
cheaper that that there is greater
diversity that there is less of a kind
of us versus them or are we having the
same sort of trends in for instance in
Scandinavian countries or Canada or
Australia or areas where education is a
bit cheaper than the post-secondary
level you raise a great point thank you
very much you and my second arm yes that
was you yeah I thought it was ironic
that Eleanor's should mention fascism
was whereas she was giving herself the
unilateral right to decide who could and
could not have free speech and was
actually even justifying the use of
violence historically to stop people
exercising their right to free speech
and of course it was Kehinde and her
that tried to analyze society in terms
of racial groups rather than as
individuals and it is in fact you even
evoked Malcolm X who called white people
Devils so it's this kind of attempt to
demonize white men as an exploiter class
that is gives you them
the self-appointed right to decide who
can and cannot have free speech and this
isn't itself a form of fascism thank you
very much okay so you're gonna deal with
demonizing white men there's one more
hand this lady here no there's a lady
who has the mic yes oh hi Andy Andrews I
have a question for you um very briefly
i am brazilian Brazilian Portuguese my
boyfriend is British Caribbean black so
we had a very we have very heated
discussions about these sort of things
and in a nutshell my question is cuz I
was talking to him about this yesterday
actually he was explaining how he was
basically repeating a lot of the things
that you say how society is sort of
built obviously against minorities it's
it's it's Britain like it's it's built
on we know the history its exclusionary
you cannot get into university these
days if you do not have a lot of money
my question is because in a nutshell
what I argued with him was I recognize
what he says in terms of you know white
privilege system being built against
certain minorities all of that I agree
what my argument was in order to find a
solution
it would be more beneficiary it would be
more of a solution to to seek economic
equality because money is the equalizer
okay so how do you think money in making
it accessible to everyone would just
sort of solve a lot of the problems that
you raise thank you very much indeed
okay well you're so excited I can tell
anything I'm gonna let you just take on
your your demonizing of white men
head-on favorite things to do like it
makes for great apart from making for a
great Saturday night demonizing white
men it's not actually what we're doing
okay we're talking about being able to
examine historical processes by
which some people by virtue of their
position in terms of race composition
class composition gender move through
the world in different ways now that's
not dividing people into good and bad
that's precisely the opposite it's
saying that we are all implicated in
different ways in an incredibly complex
political system and frankly that no one
comes out with their hands clean and
that's ok because that's the first
movement to under to bridging
understanding you have to acknowledge
and embrace difference and in order to
try and sort resolve the systems that
produce that difference insofar as being
a fascist is concerned that was weird
the point was that the point was who is
making the choice well Quinto was the
one saying the students now and the
minority students and the people who who
have not always belonged in these
institutions now get to make the rules
do you get to rate the rules and me I
mean I have other things to do
um and I am a Democrat I think that we
should have a proliferation of more
voices more diverse forces getting a say
in who gets access to these platforms
and I think it's it's not up to me it's
up to all of us to decide what that
looks like and not just all of us quite
frankly because it's a very white
audience and people pay 30 quid to be
here so we need an even more diverse set
of people so it's deciding that so it's
not up to everyone to decide on cancer
it's showing up to minorities to decide
um I think I think we need to we need to
have a sense of first of all a kind of
democracy that assesses everyone as
equals and then bolt on strategies that
acknowledge the fact that if you are
from a minority you will have certain
access to certain experiences certain
knowledge --is that are relevant when
making these decisions that that if you
are white or if you are a woman say you
might not
the media access to and that's just a
case of giving people the necessary
knowledge they need to make that
decision quickly I mean so first of the
America mix actually stopped calling
white people Devils but I keep getting
reasons why we should just go back to
you right and I think I think that's
maybe one of them and I have jokes but I
really want to say look I mean the idea
that talking about racial groups is the
problem is complete nonsense look at any
statistic will tell you that this
society is racist I mean just
fundamentally races so to not talk about
it is to collude in racism and I'm gonna
go back to the sisters point to raise
earlier because this this the way that
we're viewed is really part of this and
tells you one of the problems of
university so for example I went to
university day in jeans and trainers I
never do this at university because when
I do this usually even though I've been
a member of staff for years I get
harassed by security
I have staff questioning me where I'm
going in the building so as he's anxious
going into work dressed like this that
were usually dressed right
that's what is like at university and I
go to Burnham City I work at Birmingham
City which is one of the most diverse
universities in the in the country
so imagine me as a black man Cambridge
or Oxford that's the kind of violence
we're talking about this says that we
need to have safe spaces that's the kind
of racism we're talking about that says
actually we need to have some kind of
protection from this so the idea that
we're raising this issue as a black
person is the problem is frankly one of
the most racist and terrible things you
could possibly say that's a problem with
this whole debate really I'm going to
ask you to respond to the question that
we had at the beginning do cheaper
institutions find diversity easier or
the opposite I don't know if there's any
work on that and to go back I think that
one also came to Yuka Hindi to the lady
with the Brazilian partner who said it
all comes back to economics presumably
that is a very simple yes isn't it not
on universities because there is this
kind of idealization of what before they
were fees I went to university in there
was was very minimal fees my sister went
to university and it was free and the
problems were exactly the same the
problem is the institution and whether
you pay for it or whether you don't
they still did those pressures is still
in the curriculum we still got the staff
we still got that history so I don't
think you should pay for university but
that's not that sounds like a very easy
simple solution but it actually wouldn't
deal with the institutional problem for
more questions because and I think we're
going to have times up I can't see so
just choose me some good hands if it's
for white maybe you've know I'm gonna
make them sit down but choose me some
good hands yes yes yes and yes on the
left side yeah I was just wondering
you've talked a lot about the benefits
that you think there are of trigger
warnings safe spaces no platforming but
I don't feel it's been addressed at all
whether this relates to harming young
minds on the left so the debate here and
I wonder what you have to say directly
relating to these and harming young
minds or not okay so do trigger warnings
harm Minds the actual the trigger
warning does that harm minds okay next
one I'm going to ask everyone to be as
prompt brilliantly prompt and sort of
synced as that because then we'll get
everyone in number two where's number
two oh yes number three go high but go
on then sorry I can't see so I just want
to play devil's advocate a little bit
and I want to ask creating safe spaces
for like marginalized groups such as
maybe Colored People or LGBTQ or women
do you think that creating those safe
spaces is actually allowing us to
backtrack and actually pushing them away
from creating diversity actually
isolating them and saying you know this
is our own little comfortable bubble
okay
isn't that making us regress okay thank
you very much yeah hello yeah I'm
half-black and half-white and the lady
in front of me she was Brazilian she's
got a black boyfriend and that goes
black over there there's a Jewish man
sitting over there like what I say is
when you Iceman is loud
like I'm looking at this room I don't
really care that anyone's white like
because there's a lot of because you're
saying our COC of 80% white beef when
it's like that all the time
wait so you're that's what you're seeing
as a as a black man yourself here but
I'm not seeing that so I don't and I
don't like how you are okay and I don't
like how you're putting you and me in
the same category because all these
white people are different in their own
rights and me and you are different and
I don't I don't make sense
okay number four yeah thank you yeah
I've never let my color or my sex get in
the way of the progress that I wanted to
make I've managed to break the glass
ceiling just through hard work and I've
never made any excuses for you know
where I wanted to go I think that if you
see no color and you see no prejudice
then you get it reciprocated thank you
very much okay right it's fair to say
that more of those questions came to you
to clean they you answer the gut there
who gave this last question yeah I just
fell oh I guess maybe it's a really
moving moment where we have all of these
wonderful exceptions to the rule that
the societies actually built are serious
issues of racial discrimination I mean
me and my look the idea that we're gonna
disagree cause of black who said that my
point is that whether you like it or not
you were seen as a black man and whether
you like it or not that's gonna have an
impact on your life now you can live in
a dreamland where you think it does not
but that's up to you right you stay
there am I gonna set a real level
because one of the problems with this
debate is this idea that the route to
equality is we sit down reason it out
and we come to this wonderful new utopia
we have been on the right side of the
argument for 500 years it has gotten
those are nowhere that is not how
progress happens it's simply not that's
not how progress happens progress
happens through organization when people
come together when people do things like
I don't know protester races speak a
university that would be able to bring
in the lady number two who said by
creating these self safe spaces whether
it's LGBTQ or a mixed-race L space or a
black cell space or a female cell space
all you're doing is isolating yourself
off into your own bubble but what one of
the things you can find evidence for
both in the UK and in America is when
you have groups African Caribbean
societies or your African American
groups those spaces actually because the
unit's because this university generally
is so is so problematic having no spaces
of safety in that space of where you can
just do things differently even if it's
simple things like cultural things are a
huge part of building resilience all the
evidence will show you that if you're in
these groups you do better at university
so actually I've completely disagree all
the evidence tells us that having
having no spaces helps to prepare you
better and do better in the University
Society I'm gonna let you Eleanor answer
the question about trigger warnings does
that actually make people safer and
bring in if you like your own experience
of the lady who said oh that she'd done
it on her own merit and didn't think
about her gender or her color okay so
the BBC has been doing trigger warnings
for 50 years and no one has had a
problem with it until like women and
queer people and people of color started
getting a say in what those trigger
warnings look like so if they harm Minds
we're all harmed by them as soon as we
switch on radio for and so to think
about this kind of like you know the
trigger warning as like a cosseting
mechanism when really it's about you
know giving people the kind of equipment
they need to address possibly difficult
topics I think is a mischaracterization
and also just for the record woods I am
I Jen and I spat I've been through the
wringer of student activism which and
I've been you know I was at Occupy is
like a school child I went on the
student protests I've been there man and
the number of times I have actually seen
trigger warnings used yes I'm gonna I'm
gonna bring Jonathan in and to end with
him is there anyone here who has a
problem or has a question that directly
relates to what he has been saying that
you would like to tackle head on yes arm
right here this is going straight
Jonathan yeah yeah that's lovely thank
you very much and then we're gonna end
here but I will let you two answers
Chris hello hi so I'm a student at
statistics and last week we learned
about spurious correlation and as a
social scientist no doubt you've do you
also use statistics when you've in your
papers and so these phenomenon of the
rise of overprotection
and the rise of psychological problems
in young
what is a statistic of significance that
leads you to conclude the causality
between these two phenomenons like other
than just correlation so on that
question we are very careful you're
right that most most studies of human
outcomes over many years can't be done
experimentally so it is correlational so
in the book we're very careful about
that we draw on research that at least
tries to look at time lag so if
something changes in one place and one
point in one place in a different time
in a different place that and then the
outcomes differ that is at least some
reason to infer that there's probably
causality we are very careful about that
you're right frankly we don't know why
the depression rates are rising and we
deal very carefully with that we say
here the hypotheses here's the reason to
think this we don't know why they're
rising so quickly in the Anglosphere in
particular but I'd like to adjust a
broader question of the question we were
here to address which one of the
questioners asked so at the end of this
90 minutes together what do you think do
you think that freeze that trigger
warnings no safe spaces and no
platforming or harming young minds are
helping them you've heard two people say
that they're generally helpful and at
least we're generally on the side that
they are at least not helpful and
possibly harmful we did a lot of we
talked to a lot of clinical
psychologists about trigger warnings
you're absolutely right
that they're very rare they're not used
often although the New York Times had an
article yesterday they're now in
theaters if you go into a play in
America you might now see a trigger
warning they're likely to become common
in the future but you're right they have
not been common on campus yet but it's
an empirical question whether they help
people who have PTSD that is not a
question that we can just guess that oh
it would probably be helpful to them
that is an empirical question to be
addressed by clinical psychologists
who've done the research on it we spoke
to a lot of clinical psychologists who
work on PTSD and they they all said the
same thing exposure to the thing that
you are afraid of in a graduated way
where nothing Bad's can happen is the
cure for it moving away from reminders
is a symptom of PTSD it is not a cure
there are also a few experiments that
have tried experimentally to either give
or not give they suggest either no
benefit
we'll be some backfire we don't know the
answer yet good experiments are going to
be done it's an empirical question so
far there is very there is no evidence
to suggest that trigger warnings are
helpful to people with PTSD on the
broader question of this whole package
trigger warning safe spaces this
approach to your University this
approach to the world of ideas and books
and speakers is this helpful to students
or harmful and I would submit and I
think we show the evidence in in the
book that thinking this way makes you
see more threats makes you have more of
an external locus of control because
these vast forces are what determine
your outcome and my god does it waste
your 4 years when you could be learning
and instead you're focused on defeating
the enemy I think I'll end it there quit
while you're ahead on that note we're
going to thank all of our speakers thank
you all very much indeed
[Applause]